bonjour donc effectivement la métrologie
discipline méconnue pour voir
quelquefois inconnu et qui pourtant
rarement à 8 mois et qui pourtant
impact largement nos vies je vais
essayer de vous en parler à travers une
série de sauts dans le temps et dans
l'espace
un saut de 5000 ans
on est
devant une invention extraordinaire
génial l'écriture
probablement largement liée au commerce
et aux impôts et qui favorise évidemment
le calcul la géométrie et ses
connaissances essentielles pour
construire des ensembles comme la
pyramide de khéops et pour tout cela il
faut mesurer
le mot mesure un peu d'étymologie le mot
mesure vient du grec metron
le mot mettront signifie la mesure où
quelquefois on confond un peu entre la
mesure est l'instrument qui permet
d'évaluer exactement lorsque on comprend
comment d'une pinte c'est à la fois ce
qu'il ya dans le vert et le verre
graduée qui correspond au volume d'une
pinte mais ça correspond également à sa
une signification qu'il y ait à
l'expression française faire les choses
avec tact et mesure c'est-à-dire en fait
raisonnablement à partir de métro on
associe logos le discours et on
construit la métrologie qui est donc la
science de la mesure
à cette époque là
évidemment pour mesurer ils ont besoin
de définir des unités et les unités sont
essentiellement basées sur les
extrémités distale du corps humain et
puisque finalement la mesure est lié à
l'impôt à la construction sert
finalement pouvoir régalien
eh bien on se retrouve avec la coudée
royal le pied impérial et autres machins
du du même genre
alors on fait un saut on se retrouve au
xviiie siècle en france
et
les unités sont devenues folles
on a une diversité d'unités absolument
extraordinaire qui change entre les
villes quelquefois c'est le même nom
mais ça veut pas dire la même chose
quelques fois même en change entre deux
châteaux et lorsque le roi louis saez
convoque les états généraux en 1785 en
1789 pour préparer ça on écrit des
cahiers de doléances et dans ses cahiers
de doléances ces problèmes d'unités sont
fortement
évoquée avec l'idée d'uniformiser tout
ça et surtout de rendre les choses
vérifiable
alors il y en a une que j'adore c'est
l'année avec un seul n
c'est la quantité de grains que peut
porter un âne
voilà alors montrez moi un âne de
référence parce que moi des ânes j'en
connais mais c'est pas des références
alors
l'assemblée nationale sont non pas
et le décret du 8 mai 1790 supplie le
roi de mettre en place un système
uniforme d'une de poids et mesures ce
qui sera fait d'y associer l'angleterre
donc sa réussite avant l'heure ça
marchera pas
alors ça c'est la dimension
commerciale voire fiscale
on a une autre dimension qui à dimension
scientifique
alors je vais a reculé de 50 ans à peu
près on est au milieu du xviiie siècle
en 187 newton avait démontré par le
calcul que la terre devait aplatit au
pôle et donc vers le milieu du xviiie on
organise des expositions lointaine et
notre héros charles-marie de la
condamine est un des savant qui part
vers le pérou pour faire de la
cartographie et
vérifier vérifier ça il ya aussi des
savant anglais est un des grands
problèmes de l'expédition sera des
problèmes d'unités donc quand la
condamine rentrer il écrit un rapport à
l'académie royale des sciences et en
particulier il suggère d'appuyer les
unités sur les constantes fondamentales
de la nature c'est un point clé
évidemment parce que les élites est
passée était lié au pouvoir le pied du
roi et c est donc là si c'est lié à des
constantes de la nature eh bien ça peut
être universel et donc son idée c'est
que ça puisse être
accepté par tous les peuples et tous les
temps dit il dans son projet
et donc on a les deux piliers de la
métrologie
la sincérité des échanges d'un côté
la science et les techniques de l'autre
ont défini le maître comme la dix
millionième partie du méridien terrestre
prix entre le pôle boréale et l'équateur
1993 ont défini le kilo mais surtout 10
795 on décide que le système métrique
serait un système décimal c'est à dire
que l'on baserait les unités les
multiples et les sous multiples sur un
principe d'une base 10 vous avez le cm
le dossier le des six mètres le
kilomètre etc je pense que le succès du
système métrique
tel qu'on le connaît et en particulier à
6 sur ces deux idées des unités basées
sur des constantes de la nature donc
indépendant av dépendante de toute forme
de pouvoir et la base qui le pousse des
anglo saxons qui fait 25 points 4 mm et
derrière c'est que des 0
et donc une unité à sous multiples du
maître mais qui n'est pas en base 10
alors à faire un saut dans le temps on
remonte un siècle on est vers 1880 à peu
près et
on est en pleine révolution industrielle
on a besoin de mesures beaucoup plus
chine on a besoin d'uniformiser les
mesures parce que les échanges
s'intensifient entre les pays et donc il
ya tout un travail qui réalisé est le 20
mai 1875 17 pays signent la convention
du m à paris qui en particulier institut
le bureau international des poids et
mesures qui est installée
au niveau du pavillon de breteuil en
région parisienne
aujourd'hui 20 mai
c'est la journée mondiale de la
métrologie
en anniversaire de cette signature alors
historiquement il y aurait une logique à
ce soit lui mais c'est le fameux décret
du 8 mai 1790 mais bon c'est bien que le
8 mai côté européen c'est l'armistice de
la seconde guerre mondiale
donc à tout un travail de faire cette
époque là pour redéfinir mieux les
unités ont redéfini le m donc en fait on
reprend bien sûr la valeur de l'ancien
le maître des archives mais avec une
technique très affinée avec eux ce qu'on
appelle un étalon attrait avec une forme
très particulière en x là comme sur la
photo est le monsieur qui fait un gros
travail là dessus c'est henri fresco
origines de tresses quart partant ses
envies tresca est donc aujourd'hui là
vous êtes assis dans l'amphithéâtre
tresca on a donné ce nom en hommage au
travail de tresques assure sur le m
on définit on
met en place dans qu'un le kg alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait en angleterre ont
fondé barre
de platini rivier dont 90% de qualité
une platine 10% d'iridium ont taillé
dans ses bars des cylindres de 39 mm de
diamètre et 39 mm de hauteur qui
correspondent en fait à un kilo selon
l'ancienne définition il à elle son pays
sont polis et donc chacun des 17 pays
signataires de la convention du maître
soit le sien et le bureau international
des poids et mesures en reçoit un en
particulier qu'on appelle le prototype
qui reste l'unité du kg jusque jusque
récemment j'en reparlerai et on met des
témoins donc fabriqué au même moment au
même moment et c'est dans un coffre-fort
au niveau du bureau international des
poids et mesures
protégés par des cloches de verre et ce
prototype a été le kilogramme
matérialiser jusque très récemment
et donc
la métrologie
est organisée en particulier autour du
bureau international des poids et
mesures
structurés à la fin du 19e siècle le
bureau international des poids et
mesures et donc une agence finalement
intergouvernementale scientifique qui
est certainement une de celles qui
impacte le plus d'un point de vue
international
sur sur un tas d'aspects
ont refait un saut dans le temps en gros
on arrive ces jours ci enfin dans notre
époque
en 1983
on redéfinit le m
on
on écrit que le m et la longueur du
parcourue par la lumière dans le vide
pendant 1 sur 299 millions 792 1458 de
seconde or le chiffre exact importe peu
par contre c'est une vraie révolution
intellectuelle parce qu'avant on définit
le m on mesure la vitesse de la lumière
on donne donc la vitesse de la lumière
avec une incertitude on retourne le
processus on dit einstein a raison la
vitesse de la lumière dans le vide
constantes fondamentales de la physique
qu'on note d'habitude petit c'est un
doux le petit ses quais sur l'écran et
on en déduit le m ce qui fait bien sûr
qu'on aurait dû nous mettre avec une
incertitude alors pourquoi c'est
possible ça en 1983 et que c'était à
tout à fait impossible au 19e siècle
parce que ça suppose la maîtrise de ce
qu'on appelle les lasers accordé en
fréquence etc évidemment ça n'existait
pas en 19ème siècle alors ça pose un
gentil problème ça
parce que imaginez vous achetez un
mètres de tissu et puis voilà vous vous
demandez si ça fait bien à m
alors au xviiie siècle vers 10 797 on a
installé à paris des plaques de marbre
comme ça ça c'est près du sénat donc une
plaque de marbre avec deux petit taquet
en laiton et donc c'était facile d'aller
dans la rue et de mettre le groupe tissu
pour savoir si ça fait 1 m bon
évidemment pour comparer le m de tissu à
la longueur du trajet parcourue par la
lumière dans le vide c'est une autre
histoire
ok alors du coup comment on fait et bien
en fait ce qui va se passer c'est que
vous mesurez votre votre morceau de
tissu avec un mètre ruban qui est
fabriqué vérifié par un industriel
cet industriel
vérifie ce tariel auprès d'un
laboratoire qui est mieux équipé que lui
et ses laboratoires mieux équipées et
puis on remonte comme ça
jusqu'au laboratoire national de
métrologie et d'essais qu'on appelle lé
ne qui est notre institut national de
métrologie qui matérialise avec des
lasers accordé en fréquence lemaitre
tel qu'il est défini par le sii est donc
on a une chaîne comme ça d' opérations
qui permettent de passer d'une opération
d'un vie de tous les jours jusqu'au au
meilleur niveau national ça c'est une
logique verticale et puis pour que ça
fonctionne il faut que le système soit
cohérent entre les pays et donc on va
comparer les pays entre eux dans une
logique horizontal et ça c'est l'une des
tâches clés du bureau international des
poids et mesures
jeudi 20 mai 1875
signature de la convention du m à paris
20 mai 2010 neuf c'est un anniversaire
aussi aujourd'hui mise en place de façon
définitive
d'un système international d'unités
entièrement basé sur les constantes
fondamentales de la nature enfin presque
la seconde c'est une propriété atomique
sur le césium 133 ça veut dire qu'en
fait 20 mai 2019 on a fini le programme
de la condamine et qui consistait à
entièrement basé le système sur des
constantes fondamentales de la nature
alors c'est pas forcément toujours
facile à comprendre vous avez par
exemple kg qui est basée sur la
constante de planck
je vais pas vous faire un cours tout de
suite sur la constante de planck de
l'ordre de 6,6 dix puissance moins 34 m
quelques kilomètres carrés seconde
moisins vous voyez un petit peu ce que
je veux dire en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que pour expliquer aux
gens le lien entre le kg et la constante
de planck c'est certain qu'il va falloir
faire un peu d'effort de pédagogie alors
pourquoi on fait ça
mais en fait on fait ça pour voir des
unités mieux défini qu'on va pouvoir
matérialisé avec des incertitudes plus
faibles et des unités qui seront
universel et pérenne on sait que le
kilogramme étalons pose un gros problème
de dérive alors vous allez me dire c'est
un gros problème de dérive sait combien
ces 2 microgrammes par ansa pas
gigantesque mais ça finit par peser et
lorsqu'on commence à faire des choses
extrêmement extrêmement précises pour
utiliser ce mot là ça pose effectivement
des problèmes
je vous fais grâce de la constante de
planck
alors dans tout ça finalement mesure et
qu'est ce que c'est
je vais emprunter quelques mots à marc
humbert
qui est le titulaire de la chaire de
métrologie du quidam le conservatoire
national des arts et métiers qu'est ce
qui nous dit marc
marc qui nous dit
mesurer c'est comparer
c'est comparer une grandeur inconnu la
masse de mes pommes
avec une grandeur prise en référence la
masse marqué à l'aide d'un instrument la
balance
s'est exprimé le résultat
allait d'une valeur numérique j'ai un
associé à une unité qui rappelle la
nature de la référence j'ai un kilo
pas seulement c'est pas fini
en fait ça commence
parce que rien n'est parfait donc en
fait quand je pose mes pommes sur la
balance je sais pas que j'ai un kilo
alors qu'est ce qui se passe si la
balance me dit 1,2 kg
je paye 200 g de pommes que j'ai pas
c'est pas juste
et qu'est ce qui se passe si la balance
me dit 800 grammes
jeu on ne fait qu'un doute 200 g en fait
en fait je le sais pas parce que je sais
pas que j'ai un kilo par contre le
commerçant finira par faire faillite
parce que s'il donne gratuitement 20 %
de sa matière ça va pas râler et donc en
fait il faut associer au résultat une
incertitude
qui chiffre le doute que l'on a sur le
résultat
alors évidemment une incertitude
raisonnable on n'a pas besoin de micro g
quand on parle des pommes
et dans d'autres domaines effectivement
on va avoir besoin de certitudes
extrêmement faible pour vous donner une
idée les satellites galileo vous avez au
dessus de vos têtes pour faire
fonctionner le système de positionnement
le décalage en une joute d'une journée à
ya deux horloges atomiques à bord et le
décalage sur une journée correspond à
peu près à une seconde sur 3000 ont
sinon ça fonctionne pas vous n'êtes pas
capable de partir en randonnée sans une
carte ign
alors la métrologie c'est plus à
la métrologie y en a partout en
particulier dans les opérations
commerciales mais également en matière
scientifique en matière technique et à
tas de gens vont leur vie
professionnelle qui sont impactées
directement par par la métrologie
est en fait j'en ignore que la
métrologie existe savent pas bien ce que
c'est et donc au fond si tout cela
fonctionne correctement si le système
international d'unités fonctionne si les
balances vous donne des résultats
corrects avec une incertitude
raisonnable c'est parce que la
métrologie fait pas trop mal son boulot
et comme le boulot est bien fait pendant
par leur bar parce qu'on parle jamais
des trains qui arrivent à l'heure je
suis remercié
[Applaudissements]